moi j'ai entendu ce qu'a dit monsieur
faraj la seule voie possible pour celles
et ceux qui ne sont pas convaincus de
l'europe c'est de sortir de l'europe
tout simplement c'est il n'y a pas
d'autre voie et et celle là elle est
terrible mais elle est celle finalement
de la logique de sortir de l'europe de
sortir de l'euro de sortir de schengen
et même si vous pouvez de sortir même de
la démocratie parce que parfois en vous
entendant je me pose cette question
est-ce que vous vraiment vous voulez
participer un espace commun et bien
et bien ce que j'appelle ici ce n'est
pas l'abandon de la souveraineté c'est
la souveraineté et la souveraineté n'a
rien à voir avec le souverainiste la
souveraineté européenne est capable de
décider pour nous mêmes et d'éviter que
ce soit le retour au nationalisme aux
populistes aux extrémistes qui nous
impose aujourd'hui d'aller dans un
chemin que nous n'avons pas voulu